>> CHRIS: IT'S TIME TO PLAY
ANGRY OLD ENGLAND.
(APPLAUSE)
UK NEWSPAPERS ARE ALMOST AS
DEPRESSING AS THE WEATHER,
ALMOST EVERY STORY SEEMS LIKE IT
WAS WRITTEN BY MORRISSEY AFTER
A CODEINE BINGE.
THE BLOG ANGRY PEOPLE AND
THE LOCAL NEWSPAPER CATALOGS
THE STATUS SUBJECT OF THE
CROWN.
WE'RE GOING TO SHOW YOU SOME
BRITS FROM THE BLOG AND FOR
250 POINTS YOU HAVE TO GIVE
US THE HEADLINE FROM THE
STORY THAT ACCOMPANIES IT.
FIRST ONE THIS BUMMED BUNCH.
THIS BUMMED BUNCH.
TIM.
>> LOCAL THEATER GROUP
STAGES RARE REVIVAL OF ONE
DALMATIAN.
>> CHRIS: POINTS, RHYS DARBY.
>> DOWNTON ABBEY JUMPS THE
SHARK WITH 80 FLASH FORWARD.
(APPLAUSE)
>> CHRIS: NEXT ONE.
THIS CRAFT PAIR.
WHAT ABOUT THESE TWO?
I AM ALREADY HAUNTED BY THEM.
RICH?
>> SAME SEX MARRIAGE NOW
EXPANDED TO BAG OF RICE.
>> CHRIS: RHYS DARBY.
>> PAUL BLART'S SISTERS --
(LAUGHTER)
COLLECT A BAG OF HIS DRIED
[BLEEP].
>> CHRIS: OF COURSE, YES.
>> A BIT ON THE NOSE?
>> CHRIS: HOPEFULLY NO,
HOPEFULLY IT'S ALL IN THE BAG.
POINTS.
LAST ONE --
THESE SCHOOL CHUMS, LOOK AT
THAT.
RHYS.
>> SCHOOLCHILDREN PUSH
STEPHEN HAWKING THROUGH WORM
HOLE TO ANOTHER DIMENSION.
>> CHRIS: YES, POINTS.
>> SO-- IT LATER TURNS OUT -- IF
YOU PAN OUT, HE'S JUST ON
THE FLOOR AND--
>> CHRIS: IT'S JUST A WINDOW.
YEAH, CUZ I WAS KIND OF
WONDERING WITH THAT STORY,
THEY'RE BASICALLY TAKING A
PICTURE FROM THE OTHER SIDE
OF THE DIMENSION.
>> THEY ARE, THAT IS STEPHEN
HAWKING TAKING A PICTURE
BACK.
I DON'T KNOW HOW HOW HE'S
DONE IT BUT HE'S TURNED
AROUND, YOU KNOW.
>> CHRIS: AMAZING.
>> AND HE'S TAKING A PICTURE
OF OUR WORLD.
AND WE HAVE LOST HIM NOW BUT
HE MADE IT, HE FINALLY FOUND
TIME TRAVEL.